alors est-ce que vous avez retrouvé
gaston defferre dans ce livre bien j'ai
été retrouvé mais je ne sais pas si je
suis très bons juges parce que quand on
a beaucoup aimé quelqu'un évidemment on
idéalise et on le voit on voudrait
toujours que quelqu'un en face plus est
par conséquent je crois que c'est
d'autre que moi qui peuvent juger je
suis pas votre avis ah oui parce que
d'ailleurs là je peux pas être de
l'autre non mais je crois que j'ai
raison savez vous savez vous savez
l'histoire de ce touriste au crac
vénitien qui amenait une ravissante et
ravissante maîtresse à lui qu'il devait
se faire peindre par boldin qui était
son ami et lui dit boldin il fait le
portrait de cette femme que j'aime
énormément il fait un portrait
magnifique et puis boldini revient lui
dit viens regarder le portrait et judy
must épouvantable mais qu'est ce que tu
as fait ce affreux cette femme est
ravissante regarde ce que tu fais il
refait un autre portrait à la demande de
celui qui était amoureux et le portrait
naturellement aucun rapport avec la
réalité et il dit j'ai fait un portrait
très mauvais et qui n'est pas
ressemblant du tout et l'amoureux
vénitien lui dit c'est comme ça que je
la vois alors je crois que je ne suis
pas bon juge parce que je trouverai
toujours des défauts au livre sur
certains points par exemple bien je
pense que marion abou oublier la
quatrième ou du moins à négliger la
quatrième épouse de gaston defferre car
il n'a pas eu que trois épouses il en a
eu quatre
la quatrième a été la plus exigeante de
tous elle était toujours là
elle faisait revenir à marseille qualité
ils étaient en mer et il dînait avec des
amis il fallait qu'il aille s'occuper
d'elle et elle n'est pas tellement
tellement là pour cette quatrième épouse
c'est marseille et vous avez en fait
donner la préférence à tout ce qui est
la préparation
disons de campagne électorale qui
nécessite une certaine crise in et qui
est fantastiquement bien fait dans votre
livre
mais on ne débouche pas sur le plat on
se dit que se faisait t-il toute cette
cuisine pour lui-même la faisait-il
vraiment par ambition seulement ou bien
est ce qu'il le faisait pour une ville
qu'il a adoré alors c'est ma seule c'est
ma seule petite réserve et pour le reste
les 125 première page sur la jeunesse en
particulier et sur les rapports avec sa
famille sont absolument fantastiques je
trouve que
vous mérite grandement d'avoir été écrit
et d'être lu